Sup guys,
so we released this Boston Dynamics video
over the weekend and tricked a lot more people
than we thought we would, I just want
to break it down for you guys real quick.
It's almost funnier in a new way,
but more than anything else it gives you guys a look
as to what we did to make this video a hit.
As you probably already knew, we put a lot of work
into this video, took over three weeks for us to put this together.
If you enjoyed it, do not forget to subscribe both to
the (Corridor) Crew channel and to the main Corridor channel.
(Airhorn)
If you really want to go that extra mile,
take a look over at CorridorDigital.store, pick up some
cool merchandise for yourself,
it helps support more videos like this.
Thanks guys!
(More airhorn) YEAAA-